en los últimos años la cantidad de
dióxido de carbono liberada por los
humanos al planeta es de aproximadamente
40.000 millones de toneladas de 40.000
millones de toneladas aunque si
quisiéramos dividir a estas emisiones de
dióxido de carbono por persona
ahora si quisieras conocer la cantidad
de dióxido de carbono liberado por
persona bueno pues ya pasamos de los
7000 millones de personas en el planeta
ok hay aproximadamente 7 mil millones de
personas y si hacemos los cálculos
correspondientes por aquí obtendríamos
que cada persona tendría que liberar
aproximadamente 5.7 toneladas de dióxido
de carbono y entonces multiplicamos la
cantidad de personas que hay en el
planeta
la cantidad de dióxido de carbono que
libera cada persona ok eso es
aproximadamente 5.7 toneladas por
persona y nos da la cantidad de dióxido
de carbono liberada en total ahora esto
de aquí 5.7 toneladas de dióxido de
carbono liberado por persona suena como
un montón cierto hasta nos podemos
imaginar a los troncos siendo quemados
liberando dióxido de carbono que bueno
de hecho incluso serían más de 5.7
toneladas de árboles siendo quemados
porque los árboles también contienen por
ejemplo agua ahora de hecho este incluso
va a ser un número más grande porque
este es el promedio entre la población
desarrollada y la población en vías de
desarrollo
el promedio en la población desarrollada
ok
el promedio de liberación de dióxido de
carbono en la población desarrollada por
persona que bueno de hecho si tú eres
una persona adinerada o perteneces a la
clase media
el promedio va a estar un poco
cerca de 20 toneladas por persona ok
entonces el promedio en la población
desarrollada es aproximadamente de 20
toneladas por persona 20 toneladas por
persona mientras que en la población en
vías de desarrollo o por lo menos si no
eres una persona muy adinerada y vives
por ejemplo en una zona rural y no
utilizas el coche para llegar a donde
necesitas llegar y tu casa tampoco tiene
electricidad personas en estas
condiciones o personas pobres están
liberando aproximadamente una tonelada
por persona así es que como podemos
observar aquí se genera una dinámica
bastante interesante porque el número de
personas en este planeta lo más probable
es que siga subiendo y eso también lo
podemos ver por aquí en una tabla de la
onu por aquí tenemos los años pero están
escritos en una letra muy pequeña
empieza en 1800 por aquí está el 2020 y
esto de azul esta parte de azul de aquí
es la cantidad de personas registrado
desde 1960 hasta la actualidad aunque
hoy vamos a ver por donde estamos
nosotros nosotros todavía no estamos en
el 2020 pero el 2016 está más o menos
por aquí que nosotros estamos más o
menos por aquí y justo acabamos de
cruzar los 7 millones de personas y si
nos ponemos a observar las predicciones
de la onu acerca de la cantidad de
personas por ejemplo en el 2050 el 2050
está más o menos por aquí así es que nos
ponemos observar las predicciones de la
onu y la predicción alta de la onu dice
que vamos a llegar a más de 10 mil
millones de personas por otro lado la
predicción media de la onu nos dice que
vamos a pasar de los 9 mil millones y
que va a ser más o menos como 9 mil 300
millones o 9 mil 400 millones la
perdición baja de la onu nos dice que
vamos a cruzar los 8 mil millones de
personas así
y el número de personas definitivamente
va a subir el número de personas va a
subir ahora por otro lado también nos
gustaría que muchas personas salgan de
la pobreza y puedan utilizar servicios y
tener muchos bienes claro que eso
provocaría que esas personas utilicen
mucha más energía y a menos de que
cambiemos la forma en la que producimos
la energía esto tiene el potencial de
subir muchísimo la cantidad de dióxido
de carbono que liberamos y podría hacer
que este número suba muchísimo y ahora
para hacernos pensar un poco más en esta
situación
bill gates hace algunos años dio una
plática de ted muy famosa en la que nos
habla acerca de su ecuación de la
energía empieza hablando acerca del
total de dióxido de carbono liberado
esto de aquí es la letra mayúscula sigma
del griego y es el símbolo matemático
que utilizamos para referirnos a la suma
así es que aquí vamos a tener la suma
anual de liberación de dióxido de
carbono que ya sabemos que son
40.000 millones de toneladas y bueno
cada año podemos calcular este número
multiplicando algunas otras cantidades
primero podemos pensar en la cantidad de
personas en el planeta ya eso le podemos
llamar p y bueno de hecho simplemente le
podemos llamar el promedio de la
población porque la población exacta es
un número que cambia cada segundo así es
que está pd aquí es el promedio anual de
la población y después multiplicamos a
este número por la cantidad de servicios
que está utilizando en promedio cada
persona
ok vamos a multiplicar por ese que es el
promedio de servicios utilizados por
persona al año promedio de servicios por
persona al año y bueno de hecho aquí
podríamos no sólo poner servicios sino
que también podríamos poner bienes
porque aquí estamos hablando acerca de
cosas que van a necesitar energía y
cualquier bien o servicio va a necesitar
de energía para que tú lo puedas
consumir
hay algunas cosas muy obvias como el
transporte
claramente un auto consume combustible y
libera dióxido de carbono pero hay otras
cosas no tan obvias por ejemplo para
poder ver este vídeo estás también
utilizando energía y yo por otro lado
también estoy consumiendo energía a la
hora de producir este vídeo tengo que
mantener la computadora prendida tuve
que comer un poco y bueno obviamente yo
como para poder tener energía para
moverme y seguir viva y bueno para
producir esa comida también se necesita
energía y luego se necesita energía para
transportar esa comida a mi mesa
yo estoy utilizando electricidad para
grabar este vídeo y tú estás utilizando
electricidad para poder consumir este
vídeo así es que se está utilizando
mucha más energía en los bienes y
servicios de lo que nos damos cuenta
generalmente así es que recordemos que
queremos obtener el número total de
dióxido de carbono liberado y eso lo
obtenemos multiplicando esto
por la cantidad de energía emitida por
servicio consumido o bueno podríamos
decir por bien o servicio consumido ya
ese promedio le vamos a llamar el ok
esta y es el promedio de energía
consumida por servicio
ok como estábamos diciendo antes cada
servicio o bien que consumes necesita
energía porque por ejemplo si vas a la
escuela también estás utilizando mucha
energía ya sea por las luces que están
prendidas dentro del salón o la
calefacción o el aire acondicionado si
es que lo hay y además por ejemplo tu
profesor necesita energía para seguir
vivo necesitan comer necesitan usar el
transporte para llegar a la escuela y
poder darte clase en el salón y
finalmente también tenemos que
multiplicar esto
la cantidad de dióxido de carbono que se
liberó para producir esta energía ok a
esa cantidad le vamos a llamar c
es la cantidad de dióxido de carbono
liberada por unidad de energía
y listo tenemos aquí la ecuación de
energía y podemos imaginarnos como estos
distintos factores van a cambiar pero si
nosotros queremos que esta cantidad de
aquí llegue a cero porque si esto no
llega a cero algunas cosas como el
calentamiento global simplemente se van
a seguir poniendo cada vez peor pero
ahora para que esto llegue a cero como
es el producto de estas cuatro cosas por
lo menos alguna de estas cuatro tiene
que ser igual a cero esa es la única
forma que vamos a lograr que esto sea
igual a cero entonces podemos fijarnos
en cada uno de estos elementos de la
ecuación de la energía y pensar en cómo
pueden llegar a cambiar la población
mundial bueno pues lo estamos viendo por
aquí no parece que vaya a disminuir la
predicción de la onu de hecho nos dice
que la población va a aumentar
aproximadamente en una tercera parte la
población parece que va a incrementar en
un 30% va a incrementar por un factor de
1.3
y lo digo nuevamente estas son
simplemente predicciones son cálculos
muy robustos pero nos indican hacia
dónde se están moviendo las cosas bueno
y ahora el promedio de servicios por
persona pues la verdad es que queremos
que los pobres puedan consumir más cosas
y tengan más servicios algunos de
nosotros pertenecientes a la población
desarrollada tal vez estamos consumiendo
de menos tal vez podríamos consumir un
poco menos y bueno esta es una muy buena
pregunta filosófica abierta a debate si
estamos consumiendo demasiado o no pero
en promedio nosotros queremos que el
mundo en especial que los pobres puedan
consumir mayor cantidad de servicios y
bienes queremos que todos tengan un buen
transporte mejor acceso a médicos y
medicinas mejor acceso a la educación y
mejor acceso al ocio así es que esto en
realidad queremos que aumente ok de
hecho va a aumentar conforme el mundo se
vuelve un lugar cada vez más rico
y una cosa que si todo bill gates en su
plática de té es que este promedio
podría aumentar por un factor de 2 lo
que la cantidad promedio de servicios
por persona probablemente aumentará en
un factor por 2 y en el fondo esto es
algo muy bueno porque queremos que el
mundo sea un lugar más rico y queremos
que más personas puedan consumir más
servicios y bienes y ahora vamos con el
promedio de energía por servicio lo
bueno es que la tecnología sigue
avanzando y está haciendo que las cosas
sean cada vez más eficientes así es que
cada vez tenemos mejor aislamiento y
motores cada vez más eficientes ya sean
motores eléctricos o algunos otros
motores de combustible por lo que el
promedio de energía por servicio va a
bajar cuánto va a bajar la verdad
depende de qué tan optimista seas pero
podría llegar a bajar un 20% o
dependiendo de adentro de cuánto tiempo
nos referimos podría incluso llegar a
bajar un 50 por ciento y algunas
predicciones muy optimistas
y que bajara incluso más del 50% si es
que pues pensemos de una forma muy
optimista y digamos que esto baja por un
factor del 50 por ciento aunque hay baja
por un factor de 0.5 ahora si nos
quedamos por aquí nada más con lo que
tenemos hasta ahorita 2 por punto 5 se
queda en 1 pero la población sigue
subiendo así es que nuestras emisiones
anuales siguen subiendo con los años en
lugar de disminuir qué es lo que estamos
buscando pero ahora incluso aunque nos
volviéramos muy eficientes y lográramos
bajar el promedio de energía por
servicio en un 80 por ciento o incluso
en un 90 por ciento de todas formas
vamos a seguir teniendo miles de
millones de toneladas de dióxido de
carbono liberadas cada año así es que la
única forma con la que podemos lograr
que esto se vuelva cero es si la cee
esta sede aquí que es la cantidad de
dióxido de carbono liberado por unidad
de energía
esta se la volvemos 0 así es que esta se
se tiene que volver 0 necesitamos volver
la 0 ahora decir esto es algo bastante
atrevido porque estamos lejísimos de
llegar a esto pero si nos lo tomamos en
serio es posible que la humanidad pueda
lograrlo porque si hay fuentes de
energía que no liberan dióxido de
carbono o bueno que se quedan muy cerca
de no liberar dióxido de carbono ahora
aquí hay que dejar algo muy claro y es
que aunque estés utilizando un coche
eléctrico nos tenemos que preguntar de
dónde proviene la electricidad que
utiliza ese coche eléctrico si por
ejemplo esa electricidad fue producida
quemando carbón entonces va a liberar un
montón de dióxido de carbono o por
ejemplo si fue creada con gas natural
entonces también va a liberar dióxido de
carbono así es que incluso aunque estés
utilizando un motor eléctrico nos
tenemos que preguntar cómo se produjo la
electricidad que está utilizando y por
otro lado también tenemos fuentes de
energía
la nuclear y bueno la energía nuclear
tiene su propio conjunto de problemas
como por ejemplo cómo lidiar con los
residuos radioactivos y todo el tema de
la seguridad pero hay muchas personas
trabajando en este tipo de cosas como
crear energía nuclear limpia que sea
mucho más segura y que genere sólo una
pequeña fracción de la cantidad de
residuos radioactivos y la verdad es que
también tenemos muchos otros tipos de
fuentes de energía renovables pero sigue
siendo un gran reto para la humanidad y
nosotros queremos que esto de aquí se
vuelva a cero si queremos que el
calentamiento global vaya más lento o si
queremos detener el calentamiento global
tenemos que encontrar una forma de hacer
esto y en un sentido muy general como
civilización si nos enfocamos en esto
podemos lograrlo